[Music]
so this is the imac pro it's apple's
first true pro desktop workstation in
years and it's pretty damn good so i
made my first impressions video of the
new imac pro using somewhere what i'd
call like a mid-tier imac pro it was the
10 core the total price ran around 10
grand for that machine
the imac pro starts at about 5 000 bucks
on launch day though i did order what
would be the highest end available imac
pro spec configured with the intention
of making it my full daily driver i'm
gonna give it a shot and replace the mac
pro so that's what this is turns out to
be the 18 core xeon cpu 128 gigs of ram
the 16 gig vegas 64 and a 4 terabyte ssd
and all that runs around 13 000 bucks
and i have
actually really liked it so a couple
months ago i was wondering if imac pro
was a trap i was thinking i would try it
and it would just be my interim machine
until that fully modular new mac pro
comes out maybe this year and that may
still be true but after using this i can
really say that i can highly recommend
imac pro maybe not this 18 core one but
this is one of my favorite new apple
products in a really long time so of
course anyone considering buying one
will want to know why should i get an
imac pro over a regular high-end imac
you know you can get a maxed out 5k imac
with a core i7 64 gigs of ram all of
that for about five grand so why pay
more for this so this is everything
that's different about this deceivingly
different beast the imac pro so the
outside dimensions are exactly the same
as a normal imac which means same 5k
display but also same big bezels and
same huge chin and same non-adjustable
stand so you know part of the reason i
was looking forward to the new mac pro
is because i've never really been a huge
fan of the way the imac looks i'd rather
use my own monitor i actually prefer
dual monitors and a matte finish but
that's not to say this 5k display here
is bad in fact it's excellent it's one
of the best and it always has been but
here's what is new number one the space
gray obviously i think it's hot i would
love an even more like matte black
undertone but i know we're not getting
that so for now i can appreciate the
space gray paint the space gray keyboard
the black buttons the track pad the
black lightning cable black apple
stickers even all the stuff that you can
only get with an imac pro it doesn't
save the magic mouse from dumb design
but you know at least now it's better
looking so number two the built-in
speakers of the imac pro are actually
significantly louder and fuller and
better than a regular imac now you may
or may not care about that if you're a
pro user you probably don't use the
built-in speakers obviously don't i use
an audio device to my external speakers
and i also have this little satechi
little hub here that plugs and gets my
ports around the front and goes right
into the speaker but if you do use the
built-in speakers that's a nice bonus
and speaking of ports of course number
three is those ports so the imac pro has
a 2018 workstation suite of high
performance i o has four full-size usb
3.0 ports four thunderbolt 3 usb-c ports
an sd card reader a headphone jack and
10 gigabit ethernet which is pretty huge
for networking professionals right there
i'm currently using most of these ports
on mine so for my external storage the
pegasus the audio device the red mag
reader things like that but i have a
couple left over so i haven't found that
i need more ports but if i added another
5k monitor which you can do that would
fill my thunderbolt 3 ports but so far
i'm all right now again it is an
all-in-one but technically it's an
all-in-one desktop and for any desktop i
gotta say i usually want the ports to be
pretty easily within reach so that's yet
another reason why i'd prefer a mac pro
but i'll link to this little satechi hub
i got right below that like button if
you want more info on it and i'll also
link the 12 south stand i have mine on
as well i've talked about them before in
my setup tour video but there's that so
number four
is the built-in webcam so it's not
rocking this 1080p facetime camera
which you know this is also better than
a normal imac
but it's not that great i mean we still
have these incredible cameras these 4k
optically stabilized cameras in this
little device here but in this entire
bezel of this whole imac pro i'm looking
at this is the best i could fit
apparently
not a big deal so number five is the
vents and the cooling this is pretty
minor but imac pro is dead silent even
with a heavy edit going on in final cut
pro or a massive amount of multitasking
it seems like apple's pretty into
keeping the fan speed low on this thing
i've heard it speed up maybe twice ever
while using it and both of those times
were during rendering and final cut so
the slot at the bottom is air intake and
the vents at the top near the stand are
where the hot air is blowing out some
people have definitely mentioned that it
seems like the angle of the imac stand
would take the hot air output and bounce
it back into the cool air vent but i've
never found that the fan spins fast
enough to move the hot air out that fast
so just kind of
hot air just kind of rises and the cold
air intake takes in whatever's at your
desk level and that brings us to number
six the one that really matters the
internals like i mentioned this is a
maxed out imac pro here so this is the
18 core xeon w workstation chip the 128
gigs of error correcting memory 16
gigabytes of memory on that vega 64 gpu
and the 4 terabyte ssd workstation grade
parts and also something that doesn't
get talked about as much is the t2 chip
which is new to the imac pro but that
integrates a bunch of the smaller
formerly discrete controllers into one
like the camera's image processor
encrypted storage etc and with the
performance i feel like i've actually
noticed a major difference in the way it
feels both in heavy everyday projects
and in the day-to-day which is not
something i thought i would now you can
look at benchmarks and obviously the 18
core xeon and all the high-end specs are
going to destroy a regular i7 and all of
those and obviously outperform a little
bit something like a custom built pc but
just in the way i've been using it and
it's kind of like the eye test i've
noticed it feels faster which is awesome
a lot of the most intensive work i do in
the studio of course is video editing
and that's actually pretty gpu heavy
which matters more in final cut pro imac
pro flies through this stuff like an
imac or even my trashcan mac pro never
quite could and of course every imac
i've tried has had vega 64. so that's
important but cutting through and
playing back 8k red code at 12 to 1 or
even 8 to 1 compression on the timeline
would [ __ ] a macbook pro it would
just kind of chug along with a lot of
drop frames on any old mac pro but it
plays through almost like pro res on
this imac pro this is in the better
performance mode obviously but i can add
effects colors layer stuff on top and it
plays it back smoothly after maybe a
split second of buffering which is
awesome it makes video editing feel a
lot better it feels easier in a weird
way so from top to bottom performance
has been great you know the bottom just
being swapping around the ui and just
web browsing in safari and chrome all
the way up to the most demanding work
imac pro has absolutely been worth it
for what i've put it through so we
actually have this kind of a
unscientific scale for measuring render
times and videos out of final cut pro we
measure it in how many games of rocket
league we can play before it's done
exporting so finishing an 8k raw project
transcoding and down to 4k on the
trashcan mac pro for example uh would
you know you hit the render button and
then you head over to the ps4 boot it up
fire up rocket league and we get in two
to three full games of rocket league
before we turn around and it's done
rendering and we can upload we got the
10 core imac pro in here and it was the
same thing you'd hit render and then you
go over and fire up the ps4 get to
rocket league and we'd get like one full
game but by the middle of the second
game you turn around and this thing is
done already the 18 core imac pro this
literally happened we hit render and
then we went over the ps4 and booted it
up and there was like a little software
update for rocket league so we fired
that up and before that even finished
before we even got to start playing this
was done exporting the video but even
when it all goes normally everything
boots and you fire up rocket league
we'll get in
maybe one game before you turn around
and it's done and ready to upload
damn that is immensely satisfying
because now you you actually know that
only the most major most intense
projects will actually take a long time
to render
and more normal videos that are just a
couple minutes long
won't take forever so if it isn't
already clear by now i really like the
new imac pro a lot more than i thought i
would i am fully aware that yes you can
build a pc with a bit more for a bit
less you can customize the tower
infinitely more of course as a matter of
fact i still plan on moving on to a
fully modular desktop mac pro when it
eventually does come out but now that
imac pro exists as a product and i've
used it i can comfortably recommend it
to what i would consider graphics
professionals and final cut editors
alike it's the elegant clean super
powerful space gray all-in-one machine
it's it's the imac i always wanted at
the end of the day this is my new
full-time daily use and editing machine
for everything uh for now obviously i'm
willing to deal with the bigger bezels
and the non-upgradable display and the
totally sealed internals because the
performance is that good at the end of
the day that's what i'm paying for if
you are a final cut pro editor as a
professional
this is worth it 100 no brainer if
you're a pro using some other suite of
apps like maybe the adobe suite or
something else consider if you can get
away with doing all the things you do
now on a regular high-end imac or not so
if you're in adobe like the premiere
suite or after effects maybe not this
would definitely benefit or if you're in
like maya or maxthon again you'll
benefit a lot here but if you're in
motion or maybe something else maybe not
but my last piece of advice if if you're
considering buying an imac pro and
you're trying to think about where to
save money where you should upgrade
because it's not an upgradable machine i
would say go with the 10 core if you can
only upgrade one thing that seems to be
the sweet spot in terms of cores versus
clock speed obviously it's not appealing
to be stuck with the same amount of ram
forever like you are with an imac pro
but i think the 64 gigs of the base
model is actually enough for a lot of
people and then of course if you can
find the room to upgrade one more thing
i would highly suggest the gpu upgrading
to the vega 64. that's where a lot of
the big improvements with performance
with final cut pro and just with moving
around the os in general swiping back
and forth between spaces that's all been
improved with that so all that being
said imac pro turns out to actually be a
pretty good buy especially if you're in
the categories i described
all that also being said
modular mac pro this has me a lot more
excited for that
either way that's been it let me know
what you think
thanks for watching talk to you guys the
next one peace